damit werden aber hollywood wasser hat
vorjahr
sogar zwölf minuten
murat ernsthaft herzlich willkommen zu
cds welt oder eher gesagt zu raten heute
kommt wieder ein geniales rezept und ich
habe wieder ein gast dabei viele von
euch kennen doch schon amerikanischen
teams bewerben sich auch interpol kennt
ihn ihr kennt ihn auch und heute waren
was richtig geniale und zwar machen wir
eine kubica knie
normalerweise ist das kein männer
gericht habe ich recht ja warum das was
für kinder
genau dieses jahr noch viel größer
sondern ausgewachsene auf jeden fall mit
kirchensteuer machen
beim vulkan verletzten videoblog haben
die echt gedacht nicht mehr möglich dass
der vulkan macht damit bull kann ein
wenig flexibel zu sein weil das mit dem
niedrigen bildungsniveau das sind meine
mainz das mag deine den gewichtsklassen
seien aber nicht mehr meine achte mich
etwas besseres okay wir hoffen weiter
auf jeden fall das sind die zutaten für
den kita und zwar ich muss ja ganz gut
was erklären jetzt uns ganz ganz
kompliziert wir haben die doppelte menge
genommen weil hier folgendes machen wir
machen zwei pizzen dh die macht eine
pizza und ich mache eine pizza und wir
haben jetzt auch die doppelte menge
genommen
aber ich sage euch jetzt die einfache
menge dass wir nur eine pizza machen
könnt ich hoffe dass alle verstanden
ansonsten lese einfach was rezept steht
und zwar haben wir hier das hast du
sagst und 170 gramm butter muss das
doppel jetzt sagen und wir haben jetzt
auch die doppelte menge genommen
aber ich sag euch jetzt die einfache
menge dass wir nur eine pizza machen
könnt ich hoffe ihr habt dass alle
verstanden
das ist alles so als wird sich der jäger
eine bärenfalle stellen und selber also
auf jeden fall dann sagt mir mal das ist
butter 170 gramm genau das ist zucker
150 gramm und salz einer prise salz ja
dann haben wir hier ein 1 1 pilot tom
bohne
dann haben wir hier mail und zwar 54er
weizenmehl nein
kein 54 ok dann dann habe ich ja mail
175 und haben ja backpulver 1 teelöffel
genau
und dann haben wir hier so so nennt sich
das so konitz klar ob es okay dass man
mit gewissen druck auf 95 gramm genau
jetzt haben wir kommen zutaten weiter
wir vermischen alles zu einer homogenen
masse zu einem tag der schlüssel und so
jetzt aber jede küchenmaschine das ist
eine kitsch made sind in der petrol
version mit einem 265 schlagbolzen der
460 umdrehungen hat und deswegen immer
auch hier diesen knet kostet das was hat
das für schlappe und frag nicht so auf
jeden fall machen wir hier die ganzen
zutaten rein
es ist wichtig natürlich was für eine
reihe von neuen zutaten reinmacht und
zwar nehmen wir zuerst die butter die
butter ist hier auch zimmer war
dann machen wir folgendes dann zu mir
hin zum rhein sorgt diese salz auch ein
so dann machen wir das ist jetzt zwei
eier aber ihr habt denke an doch nur ein
highlight waren ja ich mache das nicht
okay so dann nehme ich hier noch ein
esslöffel tonkabohnen extrakt trifft
immer mehr aus im fernsehen musste
mittelmeerraum im fernsehen sieht so ein
bisschen mehr aus als eigentlich ist
also auch ich bin im fernsehen im realen
leben etwas schlanker er ist das
gegenteil
auf jeden fall dann machen wir ein dass
man langer fluss rollen richtig ich hab
dich geprüft und zwar erst mal dass ein
bisschen zu einer homogenen masse
verrühren und dann langsam ganz wichtig
langsam das mehl dazugeben und jetzt
fangen wir an mit der niedrigsten
geschwindigkeit
[Musik]
sorgt das backpulver kann man gleich ins
meer reinmachen familie genau kann ist
wenn man so einen esslöffel und marius
löffelweise meldete richtig so
genauso schön runter riesen lassen
er könnte gerade sein lassen daran
schlaganfall hast das los
warum musst du immer hätten
was genau machen das kann man auf einen
schlag machen und zwar auch hier die
koniks eingeben die show konitz und das
tolle show polizist wir sind oder
glaubst genau diesen bart fest es ist
ganz ganz wichtig wenn die maschine
juckt heißt auf jeden fall wenn die
maschine dann heißt das dass die
maschine fertig ist ist es beim hefeteig
wirklich so wenn ihr ein heftiger kritik
habt und und hier wird gerührt da hilft
man immer fest dass die maschine anzug
bis hin zu sich zu bewegen
der kopf und an zu wackeln und dann
merkt eben ist schon fertig hier nimmt
uns wahr nehmen wir hier das fett
wir sind genau so und jetzt machen wir
hier den teig und in teilen wir jetzt
mit zwei helfen wenn die bühne macht die
pizza und ich meine pizza und das team
gab aber das ist so machen
dies war nicht so
[Musik]
so jetzt kann man stehen kann und genau
mal so warten was machen meine dann gibt
es ja auch kleiner
ja ja zwischenzeitlich die maschine mit
jetzt haben wir den teig hier im juni
zusammen und jetzt in den teig einfach
mehr warum aus einem nein ich habe nicht
gewaschen vorhin vorhersagen vorhin
nicht vorgestern freuen
jetzt hätten diesen tag hier auch ganz
coole geschichte einfach so ein bisschen
rum manchen und den teig wie bei einer
pizza ganz ganz wichtig am rand
hochziehen
so und jetzt kommen die in der
kühlschrank genau wie lange und zwar
ungefähr 25 minuten und wollte das
bisschen abkühlen lassen ich hab schon
mal gemacht
darauf ist die fragen zu stellen ich hab
ich ja auf jeden fall im kühlschrank
muss mit 20 25 minuten überprüfen zu
abkühlen lassen dass an der
militärpolizist bekommt und dann danach
ab in den backofen
[Musik]
das ist doch reine irgendwer 20 minuten
marathon 3 dauer jede pizza brauchten
belag bei normalen peters die
tomatensauce und wir brauchen eine
richtig coole schokosoße
[Musik]
wir könnten noch ein großes holz und
chili reim machen warum er sagt das
schreiben werde das ist doch der wo die
gäste aus rheine gemacht haben
ja okay wenn du sagst so ein bisschen
chili ist ein genie gesagt okay und ein
bisschen salz und ganze kleine prise
perfekt so deine pizza meile pizza so
jetz simmer diese garage kann man machen
wie man will
jeder hat hier zwei verschiedene
techniken können eine andere technik als
ich hast du gott meine pizza okay
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir hier ja schließlich kein
wir haben ja ich sage jetzt nicht was
mit tätigkeiten nehmen sollte man daran
will man mehr
er wiegt jetzt süßigkeiten nehmen wir
halt machte kein belag du hast ja alles
schon geklaut
das tat ich sehr gut das geld hier auf
mehr abzuschaffen und übertreibt nicht
machen wir so in 45 minuten zeit bis zu
machen
[Musik]
was der leser hat ist innen private doch
das widerlager zu entführen auf bitte
von verbietet es ist zwar schön aus
bitte du erzählst so jetzt wo man den
siamak welt der magie des jahrmarkts für
probieren und sagen unlängst besser
schmeckt ok und schöner aussieht und
schön aussieht aber jetzt mal erste
fotos und dann probieren
[Musik]
okay sie aber jetzt auf den ersten blick
jetzt ist jetzt sagen das ist das muss
aber wie kommst doch jetzt ist für mich
jetzt ganz schnell das muster ist ja
warum er hat sich also mir gefällt dass
ihr besser weil es irgendwie mehr dass
es im nächsten jahr ist das ganze ja ja
aber ich glaube das ist das bistum
ich weiß natürlich so aber ich hätte es
gedacht du oder ist noch hier kleben
bleibt okay
auf jeden fall vom aussehen her erzählt
habt natürlich war klar wer macht denn
so eine pizza kann ich nur sagen
dreijähriger macht seine pizza
dreijährige so auf jeden fall jetzt
natürlich jetzt weiß ich leider schon
wie das ist man ja klar
und das muss alles probiert gerade hier
haben sich geholt dass du was ich nicht
fragen
wenn wir für weitere fragen steht ja
irgendwann auf fragen zu stellen damit
nur an worten das ist kein möbel teig
noch mein gott das ist es eine
trendwende ist seit ist ein hefeteig
aber wir haben zur bank bringen lassen
was sind betreibt der das ist kein
hefeteig ihr sagten so was gemacht jetzt
vier mal du brauchst nicht retten sie
behaupten geschmack aus wenn ich alles
süß oder
ja ich habe jetzt nur des kokons gehabt
das war nicht gerade deswegen meist
drauf gemacht die kommen optionen die
kokons drauf zu machen
hey robbie show kleiner merkmal des
kommunikations auf einmal hier muss
einfach wir müssen uns erst recht weil
er als kind habe ich auch mal die
shooter-fans musste heute unentschieden
das heißt er habe hier zwei zu eins
gewinnt ein foto schießen
wir wollen und jetzt macht's gut macht's
spaß machen
[Musik]